find out for morning rounds I look at
the medical news of the week and we
begin with what's being called a
scientific breakthrough a study
published this week in the journal
Nature demonstrated the ability to fix a
disease-causing gene in actual human
embryos this was accomplished using
sophisticated gene editing technology
here with more on this big development
is CBS News chief medical correspondent
dr. Jon LaPook and CBS News contributor
dr. Tara Narula John how do you edit a
gene Dana here's how they do it the DNA
in this chromosome had a gene that
causes a severe heart problem so
researchers used a special technique
called CRISPR to find and help remove
the gene inside a human fertilized egg
it's kind of like finding a needle in a
haystack really hard to do the cell then
repaired itself and at the end of the
process the gene that caused the heart
defect was gone teri you're a
cardiologist but how do you react to
something like this it's pretty amazing
you know they were pretty successful for
this type of work in a sense that 72% of
the embryos did not have the genetic
mutation for this cardiac disorder
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy and they
also didn't have any new mutations in
that so 72% which is also excellent news
this disease that we're talking about is
a disorder that affects about one in 500
individuals so fairly common and
essentially what happens is the heart
muscle does not form properly so it's
disorganized there's fibrosis and
there's no real treatment for it other
than symptomatic treatment and over time
people can develop chest pain heart
failure arrhythmias including sudden
cardiac death so for example when you
hear about young athletes who die
suddenly on the football field or in a
game many times it's from this disorder
so this would be excellent news I feel
that whenever we see something like this
and a change in technology people have
to get on board with it their ethical
questions so to both of you what are
those ethical questions there's no doubt
there's technological hurdles and there
are ethical issues but I do want make
sure that something isn't lost I spoke
to one of the author's one of the big
hopes for this is that for people who
have devastating genetic diseases for
example there's something called
Huntington's disease and that's a
neurological condition you get neural
degeneration and early death well right
now if somebody has that gene what the
couple can elect to do is in vitro
fertilization they create embryos they
look at those embryos outside of the
body and they say okay there are a
certain number that don't have the
defect and it would be 50% there's a 50%
chance well the hope is with this
technique that could go up to a much
higher percent 72% in this study but if
it could go up to 3/4 something like
that you have a much better chance of
having a successful pregnancy and you
don't have to discard all of those
unused embryos and they mentioned that
this could help up to 10,000 different
types of disorders all certain types of
Alzheimer's disease certain types of
breast and ovarian cancer cystic
fibrosis tastes that real potential for
this type of so encouraging of therapy
next up new developments in the
government's fight against opioid abuse
this week Attorney General Jeff Sessions
announced the creation of the opioid
fraud and abuse detection unit also this
week the White House's newly created
Commission on combating drug addiction
and the opioid crisis released its
interim report the language in the
report was direct stating our citizens
are dying
we must act boldly to stop it the opioid
epidemic we are facing is unparalleled
John when you look at the Commission it
obviously has a huge problem it's facing
but what goals did it lay out well I
think the very first thing they did was
they said let's declare this a national
emergency so often when you look at
where people go south with dealing in
emergency they don't declare an
emergency once you say okay it's full
speed ahead all hands on deck then you
start doing the right stuff so they said
things like you need to increase access
to treatment and that means freeing up
Medicaid funding you need to have
education for doctors about treating
pain and also about treating addiction
so Tara and I just finished doing this
mandatory New York State online
prescription course for if you're
prescribing narcotics you need to have
better access to medications like you
preneur Fein and methadone that can help
people get off of this addictive cycle
and then in addition you've heard about
this antidote naloxone or narcan is that
is the generic is the brand name of it
that can help reverse the effects of an
overdose and it can help save lives they
want to make that
more available to policemen and other
respondents and also remove the
possibility that you could get charged
for criminal you know charges for
reporting that you have an overdose or
for helping somebody who's overdose so
they're trying to try to make it so that
it's just more commonly used and usually
tarry at the same time there's a new
study that came out about opioids that
patients may have left over after
surgery what did that study show right
so for many people their initiation into
the world of opioids comes at the time
of a surgical procedure and so while
opioids are important in post-operative
pain management what happens to all of
those opioids that are unused unlocked
undiscounted well they can become a
reservoir for people in order for those
to then go on to be used for non-medical
purposes and so that's what this
research really addressed they look at 6
they looked at 6 studies about 800
patients 7 different types of surgeries
and they found that about 70 to 90
percent of patients reported unused
opioids when they looked at the tablets
that were given out again 40 to 70
percent of those remained unused and
then when they looked at where those
opioids were stored about 70 percent of
people said they were in unlocked places
like cupboards or wardrobes or medicine
cabinets and even worse when they looked
at how or when people were discarding
them they found that about less than 30
percent really either plans to or did
actually discard them in the proper way
all right finally time for our monthly
segment on practical advice going to the
drugstore and buying supplements like
vitamin D pills or fish oils is pretty
common but should you keep your doctor
informed if you're taking them what
should we know doctors yes a lot of
times doctors won't ask and patients
won't tell so it really remains unknown
and so I always make a point of asking
patients you know okay what medications
do they take and they tell me and that I
say what supplements are you taking what
vitamins I don't think of a supplement
as a medication effect think of the
logic if it's pharmacologically active
and can help you it's pharmacologically
active and can hurt you and I had a
patient we couldn't figure out why she
had a high thyroid level and I said
bring in all your medicines what's that
one no I do that for weight loss it had
thyroid in it not well regulated yes the
answer is bring it all in brown bag and
bring it in so that we can see with this
yeah I always tell people they're not
regulate
by the FDA you don't know what you're
getting when you get these supplements
they can interact with other medications
and they can decrease the effectiveness
of an important medicine cyclosporine
exactly so very important to discuss it
with your doctor bring pictures bring
the bottles show them what you're taking
doctors Jon LaPook Tara Narula thank you